Professor Chomsky in light of your
extensive work on Linguistics and
philosophy how do you perceive the
influence of Ludwig wittgenstein's
theories particularly his concept of
private language on generative grammar
Theory it's interesting and I mean his
aphorisms are interesting thoughtful
suggestive but I don't see any basic
contribution take a look at the Stanford
encyclopedia actually one of my my
favorite rabbit holes to go down so take
a look at private language Richardson
the entry almost the entire entry is
devoted to what when held at
Wittgenstein mean by this you know
that's
um and it's very hard to tell what he
meant but as far as language games are
concerned that doesn't seem maybe a very
useful way to study semantics okay but
being charitable
um I think a lot of people have this
relativistic social view of language
almost like it's a floating program